[Music]
I'm a graphics engineer be making games
since 1999 give or take and I always
wrote my graphics engines the big
takeaway for me here is that first I
don't have to do it anymore I can just
write the shaders I just write the fun
part because unity helped me with all
the legwork and we're going to talk
about first all the editor and workflow
improvements that unity is bringing to
the table and recently unity has been
really really good at presenting in the
editor how the game looks like I worked
on games where the iteration time was
something like I make a change no me but
the artists make a change in the level
compile lighting two days later
see how it looks like well in unity
that's not my works you can see me at
Lee what the content creator is is
working on but now unity is getting
better and better at also showing on
device how the look game looks like I'm
a huge fan and I always ask all my
content creators to look at the game on
the device because a model texture and
level might look wonderful on your
Photoshop or on your 3d package might
look wonderful on the editor but the
device is different based different
monitor everything is different just
check on device and unity is helping
here as well
iteration is key and unity makes it as
fast as possible then we're going to
talk about graphics which is my favorite
subject my graphics engineer and here
unity is bring it to the table the
possibility to address the whole range
of devices from low power devices low
performance devices to high-end devices
it offers no
low quality renders to address this law
and devices and high fidelity renders to
address the high-end triple a kind of
use case and finally at the end we're
going to talk about Google Play support
and how we're writing as Google our own
plugins to help you develop a chip on
Android so very excited to do this stage
- Jesse from Unity thank you hello
everyone so glad to be here today so
before so my name is JC I'm a product
manager at Unity I focused primarily on
mobile platforms and yeah I'm gonna talk
about unity and before I get into there
I just want to do a quick raise hand so
who's using unity currently I saw a few
people who didn't raise their hand what
are you doing come on there's a free
version to try no commitment just try
it's easy get started so mostly asleep
unity started more than 10 years ago
with a vision in mind is that we wanted
to democratize game development really
help creators to realize their vision
and since then well a few million users
have tried and used unity and keep using
unity but also we've gone beyond games
so unity is also now powering other
industries like film automotive
simulation architecture and many more
and this is because basically our
technology is a real-time 3d engines
really development platform you can do
2d if you want it's just removing one
dimension which is fairly easy so and
you need this focus at the beginning was
really on the Creator helping you to
realize your vision we've always thought
that the world is the better world the
more creator or we have but we've also
realized that creating is only one thing
you want to go to the next step and the
next step is when you create for serious
you want to make it a business and you
want to live from that you need we need
to be trying to enable success and the
way we do that we offer additional
options for unity users to basically
manage the lifestyle the life cycle of
their games and in particular or for
service to manage multiplayer so if you
want to create a multiplayer game we
have all the things you need to do with
unity and finally on mobile if you
choose to monetize through advertising
for example we have also a very strong
network that can be used to help you be
successful so just a very quick intro to
give you a sense of unity is not just a
game engine it's actually way more than
that but today we're going to focus on
the creation part and as Fran said in
the intro we're going to stop looking at
workflow improvement and I want to
remind some of the goals really that are
critical to goals so first of all I
didn't mention it but one of the key
thing in addition to democratizing game
development is also to be a
cross-platform engine basically you
build once and you deploy everywhere and
you know I'll be honest deploying
everywhere requires always a little bit
of work but we're trying to make that
work as painless as possible the second
thing is about general productivity we
want to give you the tools that makes
you go do you think the fastest as
possible and we'll go through a few of
those new things and iteration of on
device is really core to the investment
for meeting these days to help you work
in edit or do things really fast but
also being able to see the result of
your iteration your work on device
because yes mobile devices are a little
tricky and there are many many kinds of
devices in the Android ecosystem the
diversity is so broad that testing on
device is definitely a must
so I'm gonna go through a list of
features that are coming or just landing
in unity and try to give you a sense of
the latest and greatest that are helping
in those areas that we mentioned so
first of all in nineteen one we've we're
now shipping with unity to write the
correct on raid SDK Android NDK and
actually started with starting with 18 -
18 starting with the last version of
2018 we included the open open JDK so
which means now when you install unity
for Android and you've done with the
installation you can actually build and
deploy right away you don't have to do
any configuration it's ready to go
and if you're an advanced user you know
what you're doing you can actually do
more advanced configuration and set
things up the way you want but to get
started real fast
that's built in yeah the hub which is
the new way to install unity and get all
the different components in 19 - we're
working on a new feature to enable you
to manage notification from unity
directly so you don't have to deal with
the the low-level system operations and
that's a way to do cross-platform
notification for iOS and Android it's
going to be delivered as a package and
it's in preview currently so I didn't
mention in 19:1 the safe area under
notes because I have a special slide for
that so starting with nine unity 19 - we
are adding the feature that enables you
to detect cut out area and the safe area
is where you can safely place content
it's not gonna be behind an arch and so
now ya code you can actually detect what
are the different areas the safe area
no problem it tells you where the cutout
is and then you know where the space is
so by the way do you know what phone
that is nobody knows when you want to
guess okay so that's a big sales free
excel so if you running that code
actually exactly that code on a pic cell
three Excel this is what happens so the
first thing you start defining your
screen safe area and that's the red
rectangle that's gonna be that's being
drawn here and then you define a
variable that is the cutouts and there
can be multiple cutouts and you do a
simple loop you check that there's at
least one cutout and it's just one right
here we're doing a green rectangle so
this is really super easy to use and
very convenient if you want to maximize
the space that you have on your phones
and by the way that feature also works
on iPhone so you're gonna get the same
code working a cross-platform profiling
it's always challenging when you make a
game it works well on one device and
then on Android device maybe it doesn't
work that well so there's a lot of
profiling option unity has a pretty
advanced profiler that allows you to
look inside the game from unity
standpoint but what we've done is unity
19:1 we've actually instrumented the
build that we make so when you run a
unity game on Android systrace which is
one of the advanced profiling tool will
actually know inside the unity app
what's going on so on that screenshot it
shows from systrace which is a native
Android profiling tool what are the
different thread in unity what is the
rendering thread what is a main thread
what is the choreographer and so you can
detect from the outside what's going
wrong or whether what are the problems
potentially that could be caused by some
interference with other applications
running on the system or some weird
things that you cannot detect from
within unity so super useful and that's
available now so another more advanced
way of debugging is using Android logcat
so very powerful very verbose debugging
tool
what we've done is actually we brought
logcat inside unity so you don't have to
do any command-line tool and it's also
super useful because we give you a lot
of information that you can filter and
look through so I have a little scenario
here so this is a lock at window running
inside unity so once you've connected a
phone you're gonna start seeing all a
lot cat event coming to unity and of
course that's maybe a little too much so
the first thing I'm going to do is
filter and I'm gonna filter by the
application that's running on the device
so I've deployed this little game and so
I'm gonna just select this one and now
the logcat gives me only the events that
are generated by this application so in
this case this is the legal cat game and
as you can see at the bottom the deck of
card is empty and obviously something
wrong happened and yes this is a game
that's using asset bundles that are
hosted somewhere else and I forgot to
make my bill to build my asset so the
game starts try to download the assets
the assets are not here it generates
errors that you can see directly in
logcat so in that case I can detect very
quickly what's going wrong and then fix
it really quickly and by the way the
screenshot is also taken directly from
unity there's a little button here
capture screen is going to take a
screenshot of what's running on the
device and you can save it locally on
your machine small feature but super
convenient so now when you deploy to
your device you always you know try and
then you want to make a change so we've
introduced a new feature in unity 19 one
for Android that allows you to do super
fast iteration on code so here is a
scenario so the video just started so we
make a bill so we have a little sample
game you may have seen it this is one we
were using in our teaching material and
infinite runner so the first bill takes
about a minute it was a little
so the score start at zero and I like to
cheat so what I'm gonna do I want to do
I'm gonna change the code and start the
game at ten so I'm go going to the code
gonna do a little quick change and at
this point you know I don't want to
rebuild the whole game so what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna use this option script only
so I'm gonna recon by just a code and
not touch any asset I'm gonna ask unity
okay
rebuild the code recompile the code and
just push the new library and so in this
case I don't even rebuild a new apk
I just recombine my library push it to
the device and it takes 18 second
instead of one minute and as you can see
when I restart the game the game will
look for the new library and check into
in account and then as you can see I
cheated now I'm starting with ten points
ahead
it's available in unity 2019 one that
shipped last week and that is really
fast when you want to do a code
iteration on your code only yeah so
who's doing error development in a room
a few great so one of the key thing is
very focused on our desire to provide
cross-platform support we've brought a
our foundation which is a new layer in
unity that really gives that
cross-platform feature across iOS and
Android but also what we're doing is by
giving you this kind of common API to do
all the common things we're also
providing some extensions so that every
platform that has some specific features
brought directly to you so you have them
right in unity but for all the common
things you'll have to worry about the
differences between those platforms so
the first thing next we are introducing
in 19:1 a set of features the first one
is the possibility to record a session
so if you are playing with your app that
you've built and exploring the world you
can record all the
that happen and replay that replay that
session and use it for example as the
test script for further testing for
further tests if you've made some
changes to verify everything is okay
next in 19 - we're working on edit or
simulation so in this case you don't
even need to have a device connected to
the unity editor you can actually
simulate inputs and a real world around
you so again that's a way to each other
H really fast without even without
having a device connected so I skip the
air remote because I have a video so the
air remote is the way to combine the
power of the unity editor and having a
phone connected to your development
machine so in that case the way it works
you connect your phone to the unity
editor and then the phone is streaming
the world to the editor and all the
information location plane detection and
everything and so you end up physically
working directly in the editor but you
have the phone that is acting as the
device capturing the world so you can
iterate really fast and test and do a
lot of testing without having to build
and then wait for the bill to be ready
and play with the phone so we can really
combine that and that's super powerful
to iterate very fast so let's talk about
graphics
as I said earlier unity was created more
than ten years ago and when we made the
first iteration of unity we've built a
really powerful graphics engine but we
also built it in a way that's fairly
black box in the sense that there is not
a lot of hooks to tweak it to really get
the engine to go any direction you want
so couple years ago we started thinking
about a new rendering engine and we
built this new engine with the idea that
we want to give you a lot of power a lot
of control and also a lot of flexibility
so what we've done is basically created
the core of the rendering pipeline that
is built in C++ and around that core we
have a series of scripts that are
written in c-sharp that will take care
of all the steps that are happening in
the rendering pipeline so that we give
you full control of the rendering
pipeline but on the other hand your
responsibility is limited to writing
code in c-sharp and having to choose the
different steps you want so you can have
a really customized rendering process to
control resource usage you can control
performance and that is all ungrateful
people that from Cisco who likes to
create rendering pipeline but out of the
box we give you to run run pipelines
that are ready to use and the first one
that we call lightweight run your
pipeline is actually out of preview so
final in unity 19 1 and this is
basically the the more Universal
pipeline that is design with performance
in mind and that will work really well
across all platforms there's a big focus
on making that pipeline super efficient
on mobile but also it's really easy to
configure this pipeline to add extra
post-processing or to remove
post-processing or to have you to add
your custom steps if you want to do
special things during the rendering
pipeline so this is the one that is
really recommended for mobile and when
those are annoying pipeline which is
called high definition render
which is basically the one we use for
games that designed to run on PC console
exclusively that's the pipeline that is
used in film when we want to do
simulation so unity has being used to do
with we've shown some demo to show Lexus
car in the world that you don't even
know if it's a real one or a fake one
and that's the the run writing pipeline
that's being used for those and the main
difference is that the high-definition
run or pipeline is actually heavily
relying on the GPU compute processing
which is somehow available on mobile but
not on all mobile for sure and even on
high-end mobile has some limitation so
to drill down a little bit on the the
graphics world map specifically for what
applies to mobile so the few features
that I wanted to discuss today the first
one is one we call dynamic resolution
which is available for the lightweight
runner pipeline now and what it enables
you is basically at runtime you can
decide to reduce a little bit the
resolution at which you are rendering so
that you can really save on bandwidth on
the GPU and on the CPU and on memory and
you just reduce by a few percent your
resolution and you blip to the full
screen at the very last step and this
feature requires to use Vulcan I wanted
to mention the fact that we've been
working a lot on Vulcan with Google with
all the OEMs to make sure welkins gets
better and better and so with 19:1
actually by default when you create a
new project it's gonna be Vulcan the
primary graphic API that is selected and
of course you can decide to choose
something different but we truly believe
that Vulcan is at the stage where it is
seriously as a good solution especially
for the latest devices I wanted to
mention also a feature that it's called
optimized frame pacing and that's a
feature that actually has been developed
by Google that we've integrated inside
unity so what it does basically it
provides a better
orchestration of the distribution of the
frames during the cycle of generating
the frames for the game and Android is a
pretty complex operating system and this
feature makes your game framerate even
more smooth and so that's for me the
opportunity to highlight the partnership
that unity and Google have been having
for four years now and really we work
super closely to make sure unity works
well on Android but also Google is
listening to us game engine creators
with the input we can give to their team
so Android gets better over time so it's
really a rich collaboration a rich
discussion and hopefully you'll get the
benefits as game creators of all those
collaboration and I wanted to finish on
shadowgraph so you mentioned you like to
write shaders I hate actually no I can't
write your shader
I can't I'm sorry I used to be a
developer but shaders is out of my
league for many reasons first of all
it's it's pretty advanced math and you
have to have that capability of seeing
the pixels on the screen and from
setting that vision into code and math
this is really hard
some people can do it most cannot and of
course from the Productivity standpoint
writing a shader by hand is not the most
productive so we have created this new
tool shadowgraph which is out of preview
with 19:1 that really enables any artist
to combine using a node graph based
system a bunch of steps and it's a big
toolbox with a lot of options but it's
really super easy to use you can unlock
on that in this screenshot you can take
a model and put it as the output and
result and then you combine all
different nodes to create the effect
that you want and in nineteen one we've
added one feature which is nest able
graphs so if you end up having a giant
graph then you can actually create
subsections make them a sub graph and
then just connect them with
geography which makes it much more
readable and also make some paths
reusable in nineteen two we are
introducing the 1/2 precision toggle for
example in a scenario where you're
planning to make a game that your work
not only on mobile but also on PC and
console you actually want half precision
shaders on mobile and then full
precision on large on bigger platforms
but writing channel graph you can switch
a toggle so you can see the effect of
changing the precision level on your
shaders so visually you get the result
to see if that changing that precision
is not gonna create any trouble and much
more is coming at the end of the slide
we have a little video with a series of
cool games many with unity but with that
I'll take it away Ben thanks all right
thanks JC hello everyone my name is Ben
gable I am a developer advocate here at
Google and game developer I work with
game developers everyday to help them
make awesome games on Android and I'm
here today to talk a little bit about
Android app bundles and specifically for
unity developers how you can utilize
this awesome tool and how you should
totally be using it on your production
games so to start off I want to kind of
get a quick show of hands how many of
you are familiar with Android app
bundles ok that's a good number and of
those people that are familiar with it
how many are actually using Android app
bundles instead of an apk ok there's a
lot less that time around so hopefully
at the end of this talk there's a lot
more hands that will go up in the near
future so what is an Android app bundle
so Android app bundles are an awesome
tool that save you from having to manage
multiple apks or from having to kind of
put all your stuff into one apk and keep
it under some kind of size limit to
support all these different device
configurations so for example you either
have to have multiple apks one for the
different architectures that are out
there x86 arm you might have multiple
apks for high resolution asset
on an apk for low resolution assets or
you're trying to fit all that together
into one Universal apk that fits all
devices and so what Apple does let you
do is instead of building these multiple
apks or fitting it all into one you
build an app bundle which has everything
needed for your game to run across all
these different devices and then instead
of uploading an apk to Google Play you
upload the app bundle and what Google
Play is going to do on the back end is
basically take your app bundle and it's
going to generate and sign and
distribute an optimized apk specifically
for the device that somebody's playing
on so for example if somebody's coming
along and they want to download your
game on an x86 device they're only going
to get the x86 versions of your native
libraries and they won't get the arm
versions there so it saves a lot of
space on the user's end as well and
another cool aspect of Android app
bundles is that right now on the App
Store on Google Play if you upload an
apk you have to keep it under 100
megabyte unless if you're over 100
megabytes you have to use extension file
expansion files with app bundles you can
actually we've increased that limit to
150 megabytes so there's a lot of
benefits using app bundles and appear to
specifically show how easy it is in
unity to do this and why you should be
totally using it so the the idea behind
app bundles is all of these benefits and
saving you the hassle of managing all
these multiple apks with none of the
overhead so if you're using unity mm
18.3 and above
app bundles are super simple to build
I'll show you in a second or if you're
potentially exporting to Android studio
if you're using Android studio 3 points
2 and above it's just the build option
to build an app bundle instead of an apk
so in unity out-of-the-box what you're
going to get as I mentioned before is
when you build an Android app bundle
unity is going to generate it and it's
going to allow you to basically provide
optimized builds for different native
library and running on different
architectures so you're going to get
before and 32-bit arm support as well as
x86 native library support now you can
also if you set up your game to have
your localization files and kind of a
standard layout you can use a post build
process to also build those files into
your app bundle such that if somebody's
playing in Spanish don't only get the
Spanish for localization files and
vice-versa that's not supported out of
the box yet in unity but it's easy to do
after the fact so as I said in unity
it's super simple you just in your build
build settings you just click that box
right there build an app bundle unity is
going to generate the app bundle and you
can upload that directly to Google Play
with no extra work required on your end
if you click build and run what unity is
gonna do is it's gonna generate that app
bundle and then it's gonna generate a
temporary apk that you can test locally
on your machine or with a device that's
attached so again you're not losing that
fast iteration process it all just
magically works now I kind of mentioned
something about the size limit
increasing from 100 megabytes to 150
megabytes and unity actually goes above
and beyond and gives you a really
awesome size warning tool so what you
can do is you go into player settings
and you can enable this size
notification and what unity is gonna do
is if it's a text your app bundle is
gonna be over a certain threshold that
you define it's going to warn you and
suggest to basically generate an apk
from that app bundle and you can be able
to view what the size of that compressed
apk is generated from the app bundle so
it's a really great tool to kind of keep
you aware of any size limits you might
be going over for your game now another
great tool with app bundles is once you
upload the app bundle to Google Play
inside of your Play console there's a
new section called the app bundle
Explorer and so you can see here the
screenshot is of an app bundle that I
uploaded and I'm taking a look at it and
it shows you a lot of information about
what your app bundle is currently
configured and things like the amount of
size that you're saving using app
bundles compared to if you just upload
it in apk and you can see here it's
gonna show all the different AP
keh configurations that this app bundle
is set up to generate so here i
basically set it up such that the app
bundle will be able to generate apks
based on different screen densities so
again if somebody downloads the game on
a high density screen they're only gonna
get the high resolution assets and
nothing else
now as you've seen it's really easy in
unity to build app bundles if you have a
custom build pipeline or something it's
also really simple to use Gradle to
build an app bundle as well however
there's another tool called bundle tool
which is an amazing product you should
check out so it's available on github or
it's actually comes with your unity
editor installation and what bundle tool
that you do is you can use it from the
command line in your custom build
scripts and you can generate an app
bundle and then additionally what you
can do with bundle tool is you can use
it to generate apks from that app bundle
for specific device configurations that
you might want to test on so you could
generate apks from your app bundle to
send your QA team to your automated
testing solutions so it makes it really
really easy to again get all the
benefits of using app bundles while at
the same time not increasing your
overhead of having to generate polt app
bundles and apks for testing so it's
really simple and another really key
tool to use with bundle tool is that if
you happen to be distributing in a
region where the Google Play Store is
not available or if you're distributing
on a store that does not support app
bundles bundle tool you can add one
extra step to also generate a universal
apk from the app bundle you've generated
such that you can then use that apk on
the stores where the app bundles are not
supported so again super easy to do and
not a lot of overhead to get the
benefits so that's my little bit on
Android app bundles I hope you guys take
a look there's a lot more information on
the unity documentation as well as the
Android developer documentation so now
I'm gonna hand it back off to Fran to
finish off with some of the plugins that
we built for unity for Google Play
feature store support thanks thanks
and some of the plugins are one-play
instant we talked a length just before
this talk about playing store so I'm not
gonna go through it anymore in a
nutshell is you if you create a game
that is less than 10 megabytes of the
big game you have you can run it very
very fast and basically run it straight
off a URL which is also missing it's a
great experience to do it in unity we
provide the play instant plugin which
basically is as simple as the screen you
say you want to generate an instant
build out of your big unity game and
because it does everything that you
normally would have done manually to
generate an apk that you can upload
straight into the Google Play instant
tracker or go play Google Play instant
was my first job before Google years ago
I'm pretty new still and I work with my
very good friends here they're here on
this game plan a pop from Jim City this
is Larry story here I was my first job
Google I was having a meeting with when
I suffer Jim City and then I went back
home and my kid was playing three years
old and a pop talk about bringing work
home so I took it photo him playing with
on the pop send it to Vanessa just like
oh my god it's so cute she sent him a
plush toy with a panda my kids still use
it to go to sleep and then he sends back
to Vanessa a video thank you and then
now my kid is 5 years old and he's
having regular breakfast business best
breakfast with Jeff City it's like it's
fast-tracked into the game industry I
hope it doesn't follow me but making
this game this is a guilty game
pretty straightforward even if it was
literally the first ever unity game to
be released an instant and it's it was a
great experience now we're going to show
you a bunch of games supposed to read
about a minute bunch of games made with
unity I work with at least one of the
games here and here's the video
[Music]
cool that's it we're done